hello I'm Alvin and some of you guys  might have been wondering of the new  status on the making a big season might  be and I'm excited to announce that it  is going to have a brand new post to  someone who is very charismatic  passionate and genuine about Giant Food  and it's going to be bringing a lot of  exciting new energy into the show what's  up guys my name is toy and I'm the new  of this  I'm sharing my easy to follow recipes  and I also host a lot of delicious  pop-ups in real life now I'm ready for  the biggest and most exciting food  Adventure yet this season my friends  have challenged me to make their  favorite foods big and I mean big tune  in and watch the new season of making it  big because it's gonna be epic thank you  for supporting the show genuinely it  means a lot you guys have stuck with us  commented like shared or simply just  watched the crazy shenanigans that we  get up to but I hope look forward  anymore peace